Many of you know, I've been talking a lot
lately about youtube policies and
algorithms and how they affect our show and
other shows.
There's been a lot of demonetization.
Youtube has been bearing independent political
shows like ours, and there's a bigger conversation
about social media and censorship also happening,
which really exploded the day I was on the
Joe Rogan program involving Steven Crowder
and Carlos Mazda.
And that debacle as well as recent content
and uh, policy enforcement on Twitter.
And this has really been relevant for years,
but lately it's been snowballing in particular
with channels like ours and other political
channels because there's a lot of misconceptions
about why youtube and Facebook and Twitter
are doing what they're doing as well as exactly
what it is that they're doing.
So let's talk about how users and content
creators are affected, but then talk about
the big picture issues in social media and
how we should be thinking about them.
I'll tell you what the problems are, but I'll
also tell you what the problems are not.
And maybe most importantly, the solutions
that we should be looking at.
So on platforms like Youtube and Twitter,
the more popular you are as a content creator,
the more likely you are to be targeted censorship
and demonetization if and until you get big
enough to be exempted from some restrictions
because of a special account status that can
be available in some cases.
But then social platforms will sometimes enforce
policies differently.
When there's a high profile controversy, there'll
be accused of platforming, harmful speech
or of being anti-free speech.
They start feeling the heat from the public,
from one side or the other, and then they
start making decisions and enforcing policies
in ways we haven't necessarily seen before.
And often those enforcements will happen in
ways that fly directly in the face of both
the letter and the spirit of the terms of
service of a platform or their mission statement
about free expression and dialogue or whatever.
And sometimes they'll even end up making up
new policies on the fly, uh, right in the
middle of a scandal.
Sometimes I'll happen to agree or disagree
with a specific call that accompany might
make, whether it's taking someone off of a
platform or reversing a ban on someone who
by didn't think actually deserved it.
But the problem, as I've said before, is the
inconsistency accompany will claim to stand
for certain values and then they'll fold under
pressure when it's a better PR move to do
the opposite and it creates a completely dysfunctional
ecosystem for everyone.
And sometimes the problems are even more fundamental.
We upload about eight videos to youtube a
day and on some days as many as 75% are demonetized
for not being quote brand safe.
So we don't make any money from those videos.
Sometimes it's predictable based on youtube
demonetization guidelines, but the problem
is the effect that this has on our ability
to produce serious news without concerns about
monetization.
To be clear, I wouldn't and I haven't changed
the content of the show to stay monetized
on youtube.
I cover the stories that are important.
Youtube can and does the monetize them, but
the David Pakman show is a small business
and I need to make projections and have an
understanding of where will revenue come from.
So this application of policy is a distraction
from simply producing the best content we
can.
If Youtube will allow us to collect revenue
from our videos, that's great.
Or if a large portion of our videos will be
demonetized, then we need to deal with it
and figure out how else to fund the show.
The real problem is that by all accounts,
our content should be monetized bubble.
We don't show graphic violence, we don't use
profanity.
I'm never sitting here using drugs or harassing
people or belittling people based on their
race or gender.
Our content would be monetized were it not
for advertisers imposing their will on youtube
and youtube having little choice but to go
along with it.
This is not a left wing right wing thing.
People on the right like to say it's happening
to them because they're conservative, but
it's happening to independent shows that are
across the political spectrum, including mine.
It doesn't seem to be effecting the big corporate
media outlets that have youtube channels nearly
as much and sadly this is part of a theme
we've been seeing with youtube lately.
Independent political channels on the left
and right, the David Pakman show, Kyle Kalinsky,
Steven Crowder, these types of people.
We've realized that youtube is in general
hindering our shows and deterring people from
watching bolstering legacy corporate media
outlets that have youtube channels, whether
it's CNN, NBC news or late night talk shows.
In July of 2018 youtube actually made an announcement
that they would start making quote authoritative
news sources more visible on the platform
in a press release.
Youtube said, today we're announcing steps
we're taking with the Google news initiative
to support the future of news and online video
and product features.
We've been working on to improve the news
experience on Youtube.
We believe quality journalism requires sustainable
revenue streams and that we have a responsibility
to support innovation in products and funding
for news.
They go on to say authoritativeness is essential
to viewers, especially during fast moving,
breaking news events.
So we've been investing in new product features
to prominently surface authoritative videos.
When you're watching a youtube video, you
see a list of other suggested videos on the
right side of the page, on desktop or below
the video on mobile.
When you're finished watching a video, uh,
before the next one plays, you see a similar
set of suggested videos appear.
What shows up here, these suggested videos
is controlled by youtubes recommendation algorithm.
A large portion of our traffic has always
come from these suggestions.
Someone's watching a video about whatever
youtube suggest.
They watch another video by the David Pakman
show about a related topic.
This has been a really important source of
video views for us and it's a really good
way of allowing people to discover our channel
for the first time.
Our Youtube Dashboard tells us where our video
views come from, and we're now getting only
about half of the recommendations that we
were getting about a year ago and the decline
started right after Youtube announced they
would prioritize quote, authoritative news
sources.
So not only is Youtube demonetizing the views
that we do get, they're also causing us to
get fewer views to begin with, which hurts
the channel.
Now, this is not some underhanded plot to
destroy the David Pakman show.
Yes, they're changing their algorithm in a
way that hurts us, but I understand what they're
trying to do and why they're trying to do
it.
Sadly, this is the same reason that Breitbart
and info wars and other extremist fake news
sites don't show up in search results.
When you go to news.google.com Google and
youtube want to play.
Kate advertisers by preventing accusations
that they are perpetuating or allowing the
monetization of misinformation, fake news,
hate news and extremist content.
But the reality is that whatever the motivation,
my channel, similar independent channels,
which should not be lumped in with fake news
and hate channels are getting caught up in
it.
And frankly it could destroy many of the channels
like ours if it continues.
And so far it's continuing.
We all know the types of channels youtube
wants to make less visible.
Uh, the Sandy Hook, conspiracy people, uh,
alt-right extremism, red pill, black bill
people, uh, misogynists, racist, homophobes
people targeting others on the basis of sexual
orientation.
All of the types of channels that over the
years youtube has gotten a lot of flack or
platforming.
Youtube is fighting a negative image of, in
part being a garden of nut jobs and hate and
extremism.
Youtube wants to fix their brand and maintain
their brand.
I can see why they want to do that, but shows
like ours are getting hurt by the algorithm
to the detriment of speech and ideas to understand
how to interpret and deal with this.
And we need to have some shared starting point,
something that many people do, which completely
fails to properly frame the conversation about
censorship and demonetization is to say that
youtube and other social media companies like
Twitter and Facebook are left wing.
They say these platforms are silencing are
disincentivizing speech that's politically
incorrect or speech that is generally considered
offensive when it comes to race, nationality,
gender, sexual orientation, religion.
Many people are taking this and concluding
that the social media companies have a left
wing agenda.
Yes, a hateful or offensive speech is more
likely to come from someone on the right.
When Steven Crowder calls Carlos Mazda, a
gay Mexican lispy queer and gets his videos
the monetized, that's not something you're
really going to hear from people on the left
very often and it's the kind of speech that's
going to get you in trouble on some of these
social media platforms.
In that sense, it's possible that right-wingers
face more repercussions than people on the
left.
I don't know that to be the case, but it's
possible.
But using that to say that these companies
are fundamentally progressive or left wing
doesn't actually help us understand these
issues and it's not accurate.
Conservatives have a conspiracy theory that
social media companies are simply bleeding
heart political activists waging an ideological
war against the right.
The reality is these companies have no as
companies, ethical or ideological philosophies
or positions, they are motivated by business
interests.
These companies, by the way, as I said to
Joe Rogan are also very right wing, are libertarian,
right?
Libertarian in many ways in terms of the policies
they support and the role that they play.
Google currently in an antitrust battle with
the Department of Justice, Facebook is the,
is the subject of a huge antitrust investigation
by the Federal Trade Commission.
These companies are huge tax Dodgers.
They want to self regulate.
They lobby for deregulation the same as the
air polluters and the big banks and the gun
manufacturers.
What Google and Facebook and Twitter do every
day in Washington is in the most literal sense,
the opposite of progressivism.
Having an internal culture that's socially
progressive.
First and foremost doesn't mean that as a
company they are progressive in their public
role.
But in addition to that, even what appears
to be left wing and internal culture is often
just brand management.
They're politically correct content policies
and the way they enforce them and what they
say publicly about content policies.
It's not virtue signaling.
It's a signal to their advertising clients
and to their shareholders.
And this should be obvious.
Youtube and Twitter clearly have no authentic
principled stance on protecting offensive
speech or on combating offensive speech.
This was most recently demonstrated by their
flip flopping, embarrassing flip flopping
on the crowd or Mazda situation.
One side got mad at Youtube, youtube conceded
the other side got mad at Youtube.
Youtube then conceded to them, they panicked.
They tried to find the right balance between
protecting their image in the eyes of advertisers
and uh, understanding that that's the source
of their revenue, but protecting their image
in the eyes of the public as well.
Who are the people that need to watch those
advertisements?
Youtube isn't evil or virtuous.
Twitter isn't left wing or right-wing.
These are corporations.
They exist to generate revenue and perpetuate
themselves.
So maybe you're saying, well, we still have
this problem though, that these companies
have a monopoly on social media and they're
silencing offensive speech.
They're recklessly demonetizing political
commentators who don't deserve it.
And that is what we're faced with.
A solution that's often proposed is that we
regulate these companies that we use the government
somehow to enforce free speech on the platforms,
which is already problematic language.
They want us to treat these platforms like
public squares, established free speech protections
for all of the users.
But these arguments fall flat.
The First Amendment protects you from censorship
by the government, not by private entities.
The government shouldn't be able to force
a company to allow you to use their software
and their networks.
This isn't a civil liberties issue.
Social media companies do and should have
every legal right to maintain and enforce
their own content policies, to prioritize
certain content to protect their brand or
for any other reason that they have or none
at all, unless they're doing something like
discriminating against the users of a certain
race or religion, which violates the law.
What government body is going to enforce so-called
free speech on social media.
Is it going to be congress whose political
bias changes every few years?
Will it be the FCC or the FTC?
Is Donald Trump is thinking of doing, whose
political bias also changes every few years.
We know that the current administration wants
based on this, uh, executive order that they're
putting together for them to be the ones who
decide based on their politics, who gets to
say what and which platforms get punished.
That's dangerous.
Conservatives don't want this type of government
regulation anywhere else.
They just want government regulation here
because things haven't been going their way.
The free market has demonstrated that offensive
content is bad for business and they now want
special, big government nanny state protections
against what is being caused by free market
capitalism.
Quite frankly, or the version of it that we
have, I'm being negative negatively impacted
by one of these companies.
Youtube has hurting me financially.
They're diminishing my village and my ability
to voice my opinion, but that's not making
me lose my objectivity about the rights of
private companies or how impractical it would
be to have the government oversee social media
content.
The first step in the correct direction is
going to be for us to stop viewing social
media as one collective thing or entity.
Different social media platforms serve different
purposes.
Twitter has developed a service that's very
different than Facebook.
The mechanics are different.
The culture is different.
The etiquette is different.
Some platforms allow porn, some don't.
Some platforms a lot of spamming, some don't.
Some platforms require you use your real name
and others don't.
All social media platforms are different because
they're geared to different markets and have
different purposes.
The average person using tumbler is different
than the average person using Quora, for example,
or at least they use the two platforms for
very different reasons.
Social media companies intentionally developed
their platform to have a particular environment
catered to the market they want to serve.
In the same way that a platform designed for
professional networking wouldn't be any good
as a medium for sharing funny memes and vice
versa.
A platform designed to serve a somewhat universal
mainstream user base and attract mainstream
advertisers may not function properly as a
platform for exchanging controversial ideas
or vice versa.
Many social media platforms that are marketed
as free speech alternatives to mainstream
platforms.
Some are I like personally, others seem to
be cesspools of hate and sketchiness, but
the idea of forcing that content onto privately
owned platforms that don't want it and maybe
financially harmed by it doesn't make sense.
Youtube serves a particular purpose.
It's an invaluable service to the vast number
of content creators who otherwise wouldn't
have a platform to so lucratively distribute
their content.
It's been a really great thing for most independent
video creators.
I've been asking for a more clear understanding
of how the demonetization works as it pertains
to my content.
I'm not creating content that's fringe or
extreme or disturbing or gory or whatever.
The way that youtube is suppressing many independent
channels as if they were doing that is antithetical
to what made youtube cool and interesting
to begin with, but ultimately it is.
Youtube is right.
It's my right to complain about it.
It's my right to leave youtube or start my
own youtube if that's what I want to do.
Maybe it is actually the best business decision
for them.
Maybe it's just more worth it to youtube to
take a better safe than sorry approach to
the way that they're demonetizing me and to
just push the corporate media channels and
not worry too much about the collateral damage
to programs like mine.
In the end, I don't know that I can do that
much about it.
This is why it's so important for the audiences
of independent political talk shows like ours
to realize that the shows can only exist unfettered
through direct support from the audience,
especially if the youtube algorithm and the
demonetization stuff gets worse.
It's not just a talking point.
It's not a way to get people to sign up for
David Pakman show memberships.
It's just reality.
If we don't have reliable youtube revenue
and we don't have reliable financial support
from the audience, uh, we may have to figure
out something else.
Maybe I'll have to get a different job.
If you're not on youtube to watch makeup tutorials
or cat videos, and what you want to do is
watch content like ours that's trying to shake
things up, trying to deal with serious issues
in an adult way and rubbing some people the
wrong way.
Admittedly, then maybe we all need to assess
our roles as consumers of shows like this
one.
Even though these shows can be accessed for
free, there are costs to the creators, employee
salaries, employee health insurance, rent,
Internet, electricity, equipment, connectivity,
so many other things.
A political commentary show.
Relying more on direct support from the audience
than on Youtube.
Ad Revenue is actually probably a better paradigm
for everybody involved.
That means that if you are a patron of something
that you value and you're educated and entertained
by it instead of you and your clicks becoming
a commodity to youtube, bottom line through
your cable subscription or watching ads or
whatever else, it would mean content creators
would be more free to do and say what they
want and beholden to advertisers.
And that freedom and integrity is something
that's crucial for shows in the political
commentary sphere.
It probably also means that you might even
end up with more content creators to choose
from because they'd be better funded or you'd
have higher quality content because people
doing this part time could focus on it full
time.
As an example, when you pay for content, you're
not just getting what you paid for, you're
investing in something that you value so that
it can sustain and grow and improve.
So this is not a promotion for our Patrion
page or our membership program.
This is something I personally find not only
fascinating, but of crucial importance from
a media studies point of view, and it's something
that applies to the entire digital media industry.
These are my thoughts, but it is something
that is affecting online political shows like
this one.
And I do believe that independent political
shows are particularly important to protect.
When we see this administration wanting to
come up with new and novel ways to suppress
speech they don't like and to mandate speech,
they do like be published regardless of what
a private company wants to do.
What we ultimately need is a big picture Meta
shift in how we think about online content,
how we consume it,
and what we are willing to do to sustain it
and guard it from outside influences.
And I hope that's what you'll take away from
this today.